so why why now why now well now there's
nothing to divide besides this
and the fascist josh hawley steve bannon
donald trump
people like uh
steve's excuse me dan scavino who isn't
appearing before the january 6
select commit or isn't complying with
their subpoenas apparently they can't
even find the guy have you heard this
maybe they're not even they're not even
able to find
dan scavino has skipped town i think
what they should do
is probably check grandpa poopypants his
diaper drawer i know he's like in new
jersey now so
maybe maybe he's maybe he's in
mar-a-lago hiding in
in in the mango mussolini's closet
i i don't know
it could be he could have be all the way
crawled up in his ass
i mean maybe he's hiding in the cheeto
dust mobster's ass
because apparently the cheeto dust
mobster is is throwing out orders
on these subpoenas these select
committee subpoenas
there's uh four in particular
that they're terrified of uh steve
bannon
uh patel
uh mark meadows and uh the deputy chief
the deputy chief of staff which mark
meadows was the chief of staff at the
time but the deputy chief of staff dan
scovino and apparently dan scavino is
nowhere to be found well you know what
when someone is being uh subpoenaed by
congress
the unfortunate part is there is laws
that can make it criminal which i don't
know maybe the doj should not only look
in the school board meetings but maybe
they should look into uh some of these
congressional hearings for the january 6
where people aren't appearing and aren't
complying with subpoenas and aren't even
aren't even making themselves available
to be served that subpoena because
here's the thing they think i i i know
this is i know this is uh the buffoon in
chief
the cheeto dust mobster i know this is
his thought process he's like well if
they can't serve you if they can't serve
you the subpoena
then it doesn't exist
and you can't be subpoenaed if they
can't it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter it doesn't it doesn't matter the
congressional subpoena is completely
enforceable rather rather you work
whether you jump out of donald trump's
ass to be served or not it's [ __ ]
enforceable you dumb [ __ ] it's
completely enforceable just like any
other warren or subpoena is out there
they can enforce this
and they should
they should give criminal referrals
because at this point it does look like
obstruction and the reason why it looks
like obstruction is because the cheeto
dust mobster is telling them to obstruct
he's apparently
got his troops in line the four troops
that are on the chopping block here and
he's telling them to instruct and
dan scavino is the one who's completely
terrified so i would imagine i would
imagine that dan scavino
what we're going to find out about these
january select committees and the
information that they're going to gather
rather they have to go through the
criminal courts to get these subpoenas
enforced or they just use the
sergeant-at-arms inside the congress to
enforce these subpoenas
because they should jail these
[ __ ] that's what they should do
at this point if you're hiding
information
on on
on
a plan that
eastman had
that the trump humping eastman had
that they tried to commit an
insurrection that was the [ __ ] plan
was to stall the vote and they didn't
care by what means they stole the vote
even with violence and death even if
they had to kill because they were they
were going to try to kill mike pence
it's already proven we've seen that in
federal court
there there there is plenty of evidence
to know that these people their plan was
to go to the extent to stall this
for him and there was coordination
somewhere
somewhere there was coordination
we're gonna find out with who
and that's what these sabines are gonna
sniff out because i don't believe i
believe that the the criminal referrals
for the subpoenas are not even close
to the amount of criminal referrals that
are gonna come out of this [ __ ]
select committee there are gonna be
mountains of criminal referrals
and it's not gonna just end with a few
congressmen or a few people on donald
trump staff
i mean you got to be really paying
attention to what's going on here
that
that there's four people who are very
close to the president that had that had
to do with planning
that had to do with planning of the
january section six insurrection
that the cheeto dust kangaroo coup as i
call it attempt
that they are obstructing
congress at this point which is
completely within the bounds of a
criminal referral and that's what they
should do
they should lock these [ __ ] up
until they comply that's what they
should do just like they did all the
insurrectionist they did the same thing
to the insurrections they locked them up
locked them up
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
make them comply
whatever you got to do now rather you do
it through the sergeant-at-arms inside
the congress or you give the criminal
referral to the department of justice
and you get you get the the doj involved
i mean the doj is going to be involved
in this select committee eventually
and if anyone's of the notion that the
dodj doesn't have some of the goods
on some of the people that are going to
be outed in the select committee because
that's the slow walk here the slow walk
is the select committee doesn't want to
affect
possibly an fbi investigation
that could cause an indictment and a
conviction of someone who was
who
who tried to commit sedition and maybe
even treason
through this insurrection and planning
the insurrection so it's a slow walk and
the other reason why they're slow
walking this
is because which they don't have time to
slow walk it but they are as slow as
they can possibly get it
because the other reason why they're
slow walking it is what they want to do
is they want to make sure that they that
they undo the trump chaos machine little
by little by little by little and
they're doing that i mean we had jesse
benton being charged with taking a
hundred thousand dollars in 2016
with a quid pro quo for a meeting and a
trump fundraiser with a russian
they funneled a hundred thousand dollars
and a bunch of it's gone they don't even
know where the hell it went
hmm i wonder whose pocket that ended up
in hmm i wonder who i wonder who the
[ __ ] that could be
about 75 000 of it probably has cheeto
dust stains over or maybe just remnants
of
of don junior's fingernail clippings
with booger sugar attached to him i
don't know maybe possibly i'm just
saying
it's surmising i'm coming up with ideas
here just snowballing you know i don't
know
but it seems kind of obvious
it seems kind of obvious that what
they're doing is trying to obstruct the
select committee
with these subpoenas and it's all coming
from
the cheeto dust mobster grandpa
poopypants
mango mussolini jesus
that's where it's coming from
and the reason why it's coming from
there is because he's trying to hide
something
it's it's not [ __ ] complicated it
really isn't we've seen this time and
time again with this [ __ ] fool we
seen it with the 2016 with the mueller
investigation
at every [ __ ] turn he obstructed and
obstructed and obstructed him and how we
know he obstructed is he kept saying no
obstruction
and how we know he colluded he said no
collusion no obstruction no collusion no
obstruction no collusion which means
there was plenty of collusion
and plenty of obstruction we could see
the obstruction right out in plain day
and now we know there's now we know
there's some sort of collusion they are
at least quid pro quo 100 000
so that way a russian could meet with
donald trump at a fundraiser in
philadelphia pennsylvania i believe i
don't know if it's filmed it was in
pennsylvania i believe i believe that's
i think that's the fact
you fact checkers out there
grab that fact and see
but allegedly a hundred thousand dollars
went from a russian
to jesse benton who was on the trump
campaign they funneled it through the
campaign
and donald trump in payment of that
hundred thousand dollars was supposed to
meet with a russian
at a fundraiser
and that oh and that's not conclusion oh
okay well that's [ __ ] illegal
ask jesse bitten
and uh and uh his doug weed i guess
that's his accomplice here doug weed and
what's crazy about the jesse benton case
and if you're not paying attention if
you're not paying attention to that case
you're not seeing the crux of this
you're not seeing where this slow walk
is headed
because jesse benton doesn't just end at
the 2016 campaign
it doesn't end there
grandpa poopypants the buffoon in chief
about a month before he leaves office
gives jesse benton
a [ __ ] pardon for a federal charge
that he was convicted on for bribery in
iowa
during the 2000 and during the 2012
primaries republican primaries when he
was bribing people and convicted of it
to support ron paul not rand paul not
that [ __ ] bag
papa papa [ __ ]
ron paul
and then this guy goes to work on his
daddy's [ __ ] son rand paul
shitbox jr
goes and works on his campaign and even
mitch mcconnell
bribery
campaign bribery so like he's an expert
like he's got you know he's got
he's bona fide right
he's bona fide for campaign campaign fun
bribery
he's got the credentials
and the conviction to go along with it
cool
so now he gets caught getting a hundred
thousand dollars well
donald trump knew that jesse benton got
that hundred thousand dollars surely
he
had to have known that he was meeting
with someone because they were getting a
hundred thousand dollars and he had to
have known where he was meeting and who
he was meeting with
he had to up he was supposed to meet
with this guy
it's not like they were doing a hundred
thousand dollars to pay for rudy's
dripping hair dye
and anti-fart medicine and his [ __ ]
scotch whiskey
no
no
no
it was for a meeting with donald trump
so i knew about it he knew about it
that's that's what the court documents
say it was a meeting with donald trump
the cheeto dust mobster
so that doesn't end there though
because donald trump knows that jesse
benton knows this and donald trump knows
he's not going to be the president on
january 20th more than likely as long as
his cheeto dust coup doesn't take off
he's probably not going to be present on
january 20. he wants to make sure to
protect his ass you know and do another
quid pro quo jesse ben and donald trump
really like these you give me this i'll
give you that quid pro quo [ __ ]
because jesse benton gets a pardon well
why would he get a pardon he's already
served a sentence and he's he's
committing other briberies so what's the
hell is the difference what does he need
a pardon for well maybe it was a payment
maybe it was a payment to plead not
guilty to the charges donald trump knew
he would face
because they knew that that the federal
prosecutors was on to him about a
hundred thousand dollars
because he knew that it existed and the
evidence existed
it is not hard to [ __ ] keep coloring
in the lines in the color book
i mean jesus christ this is this is
easier than a dot to dot in the coloring
book in the trunk coloring book
it's really [ __ ] simple
donald trump pardoned jesse benton to
keep his [ __ ] mouth shut about the
russian case when he got indicted if
donald trump wasn't the president to
pardon him from that indictment
or to or to prevent that indictment by
by bullying and obstructing
his
ag whoever that was rather it was going
to be billboard or not at that point i
don't think it was billboard when he was
doing uh
pardons and i'm not sure
which it was
who was the acting attorney general or
the attorney general but someone if
donald trump was going to be president
was going to be the acting attorney
general because they were all acting
they're all acting like they were
attorney general even rather they were
they were confirmed by the congress by
the senate or not they were [ __ ]
acting like they were attorney generals
they were donald trump's nazi foot
soldiers is what they were
and we see it here we see it with the
foot soldiers not complying with the
subpoenas mark meadows steve bannon
patel we have dan scavino not even
seeming to be on the face of the earth
he's gone poof magic doesn't even exist
invisible